Film Courage: Is it better to try to avoid making
money as an artist? Should someone not set out
to do their art and also try to make money at it
right away? Erica Wernick, Personal Coach, Author
and Speaker: I believe that both can happen and
so I go into it believing this dream will provide
for me because I have this desire of course, it's
going to financially support me as well, it might
take time to get to where you want to be but I
have this whole chapter I know it keeps dropping
my book and like name dropping my book but I do
have this whole chapter about this idea of being
a starving artist because i think that those two
words you rarely hear them without each other and
I believe that you don't have to be a starving
artist and I also believe that there's nothing
wrong with desiring financial success or
with wanting to make money from your art. So
to me it's about I believe that I can create
art that is going to financially support me and
really having that belief from the beginning. Film
Courage: Most artists don't make money, especially
right up front. Wouldn't it be easier to accept
that? Erica: "Most artists," accepting that belief
equals determining your fate right. So your fate
is a hundred percent dependent upon your belief so
if you believe that most artists don't make money
in the beginning, that 100 will be your fate and
what you do when you accept that belief? When you
take that belief on you are now putting yourself
into the most people pool? Sure most people
don't make a ton of money in the beginning.
Do you have to be most people? And so can you
find an example like i always love to talk about
the example of gilmore girls this is one of my
favorite shows but alexis bledel had no acting
credits on her resume before booking that title
lead role so you know i mean she was modeling
before she had a model in korea there but but
you know breaking into hollywood as an actress
and then you know i i don't know what the going
rates were back then but series regulars now
start at like 25 30 000 an episode depending on
the network right and so you so she technically
went from zero to seven you know several thousand
dollars per week per episode and back then they
were doing 22 24 episode seasons so there's
always going to be an exception to the rule
and i think it's better to focus on the exception
than to focus on the rule i think it's better to
go into it with well i could be that exception
because when you when you accept the rule and you
say oh i'm going to be like most people then
that's exactly what your experience will be
is there a danger in not thinking
that you're part of that pool
is are you saying like is there a danger to think
of yourself in this smaller high achievers pool
yeah no i mean what danger i i think it's like i
guess the danger could be like oh but then you're
like putting yourself in this pool where people
make it and what if you don't i think that um
there's no danger in believing that your
dreams are possible in a and this is like
the high achiever right like in a really big
way in in a more committed way than most people
i i don't think there's any danger in that and i
think that like the well what if it doesn't happen
i again believe my success is inevitable so to
me there's no specific time frame that it has
to happen and i just know it's going to happen
i don't know when i don't know how i don't know
where but it's going to happen and i have that
belief throughout so there's no well if it doesn't
happen by x that means you're you're in the most
people pool you know i just don't think that way
do you think other people paying you to do
your art inherently makes it worse because
you don't have the same level of freedom to
create the art that's in your heart what if
i believed that the work is in my that the work
that is in my heart is what people will ask for
right so i think it's it's changing the belief
right it's changing the belief about it like oh
i'm going to do something that's not really in
my heart that i don't really want to do because
the clients ask me or whatever right sure that
happens and that has happened on my path you know
like i had day job graphic design jobs that i did
not enjoy but i but they financially supported me
so i could stay in la and keep doing this so
you know i've had that experience but i think
in the bigger picture um if i'm doing work that
doesn't feel good i stop doing it or i don't like
there there was you know i'll be honest i didn't
love working on cop shows because from a graphic
standpoint it's really boring you know it's like
you're designing signs for hospitals and prisons
like all like this is basically the only graphics
i do and the rectangles with text and that's
it you know it's not a very creative um you know
genre in terms of graphics and so i did a cop show
i did not enjoy it and then i was like okay i'm
not gonna do this again and then i would turn
down cop shows in the future right so so for me
it's more about like what if i just believe that
the work i want to do is what will be asked of
me can you give us an example of that happening
was there an example where you saw a show that you
wanted to do and you said that's the kind of art i
want to do though that's the color scheme i like
that how do i make that my reality yeah i mean
it wasn't that specific in terms of like color
schemes or certain art it was more just like i
would love to do something that's more creative
where maybe every week the graphics are different
you know where i get to explore more with like
different signage or different props or you know
things that are integral to the story that are
just inherently more interesting and um you know
shortly after that i did book a tv show called
chasing life which was the abc family show that
i said i loved which was a great experience and
i got to do really cool fun different graphics
you know i feel like my portfolio really
expanded from that show because we got to do
um you know so many different things like we did a
marathon once and i got to do these like marathon
banner graphics but then also you know the runners
tags that they had to wear and and then i got to
do wardrobe you know like there was a camp
and i got to design the sweatshirts that the
counselors were like there was really just variety
um and that was fun for me more so than you know
the cop graphics kind of stuff where you're
just designing rectangles with text so
um yeah and then that that became really fun and
i said okay so this is going to be my new standard
i want to work on a show that feels fun and
creative um and and you know those are the
only things i would say yes to now unless it was
blade runner then that would be cool no i i turned
down sons of anarchy oh you did oh wow no no i i
don't care how big the show is if it's something i
know that i don't think i will enjoy um i won't
do it my happiness is is now more important so
so the so the lead the colored leathers
on the back of the motorcycle jackets
that just didn't hit you yeah like okay that'd
be cool but my point was that like there you
know right it wasn't even even if it's something
even if a project is like big and well known if
i don't think that i will enjoy doing it then i
will still turn it down sure sure that makes sense
and i just want to add something there because
some people might be going oh well you have
the luxury of turning it down because you're at a
certain point in your career now where you can say
no and you know things are going to come in but
i just want to add on to that is that when i turn
down something that doesn't feel like a good fit
for me i am making room for something better to
come in right so as long as you say yes to things
you don't want to do you now don't even have room
for something new to come in so you know it's not
even necessarily about i'm at a certain place in
my career where now i can say no to things to me
it's really about what do i want to make room for
in my life even if you know the great example is i
talk about all the time people that stay non-union
you know especially actors you know when they're
afraid to join sag because once they join sag
they can no longer do non-union work
and that is scary to them because
they only know non-union work and they feel
that non-union is easier to book than sag work
right and so they like to stay non-union and i say
when you are staying non-union as long as you can
you are staying where you are as long as you can
even though it might take a little longer for the
sag stuff to start flowing in and it might be a
little scarier that doesn't mean that it won't
flow in and as long as you're choosing the other
thing it'll never flow in right so it doesn't
really matter how far you are in your career to
be able to turn things down or to you know to be
able to start making room for what it is you truly
desire it might take some time to bring it in but
you want to at least open yourself up and make
room for the things that you really want that's
a good example right there yeah i know a lot of
people they pay off they don't want to pay the
dues and they keep the eligibility status but then
they just keep keep working yeah good example.
Question For The Viewers: What was the
most helpful part of this video for you?